hi gareth southgate here just firstly  wanted to say thank you for the support  you gave the team this summer  um but also to say look we know  the last 18 months have been incredibly  difficult for everybody  and there's no doubt that the  vaccination program  is our best route out of this problem  not only for us as a country but across  the world  so just wanted to say how important it  is if you haven't had your vaccine yet  to go  and get it done um i know  oldies like me have had both jabs so we  can crack on with our lives but  for you younger ones especially the  chance for everything to open up to get  your freedom back  so much to that is going to rest on you  having the vaccine so  don't put it off any longer go and get  it done we can open everything up  we can protect the people we need to  protect and you guys will get your  freedom back  so look forward to seeing you soon